bon
[Musique]
il
riou pis vous êtes pianiste compositeur
autodidacte votre notoriété est
inversement proportionnelle à celle de
vos créations si l'on en croit votre
fiche wikipédia vos oeuvres sont
diffusées dans le monde entier vous avez
été trois semaines durant numéro un
mondial au billboard classique aux us
l'équivalent français de notre top
albums avec ceux ci
[Musique]
ça va mal et kyo lucky you dans la
pensée bouddhique c'est un monde
flottant qu'est-ce que vous avez vous
voulu dire au travers de ce titre
exactement ça ce monde qui est un petit
peu en dehors de nous mêmes et dans
lequel on est on est créatif on est un
peu en dehors de soi de cette réalité il
est vrai était qui est difficile c'est
effectivement très difficile alors il
faut quand même préciser quelque chose
il est rarissime qu'un français soit en
tête de ce classement encore moins avec
un disque instrumental à 100 millions d'
écoute depuis 2018 c'est fou c'est
presque une incongruité en tout cas
c'est un exploit comment expliquez vous
ça si tant est qu'on puisse l'expliquer
j'avoue je me pose pas vraiment la
question mais je suis très heureux
d'avoir des vies d'amende- des millions
de personnes qui écoutent ma musique et
on est oui puisque vous avez une idée de
ce que vous touchez en eux je pense que
je pense que la façon dont ça touche les
gens je pense c'est la même façon dont
moi ça m'a touché en fait parce que moi
la musique c'est vraiment une nécessité
qui a sauvé la vie et je reçois beaucoup
beaucoup dizaine de personnes qui me
disent en fait le plus ou moins la même
chose donc c'est à dire oui ça les aide
à travers travers beaucoup beaucoup de
situations et notamment des jeunes
rappelle de ce jeune garçon qui a perdu
son frère et qui écouter des morceaux de
drive pendant des semaines et il m'a dit
c'est ça qui m'a aidé à tenir et moi ma
musique c'est ce qui m'a aidé à venir
vous composez également des bandes
annonces pour hollywood on peut citer
notamment de danis girl de chypre
voiture monsieur dorner vous vous
illustrez également des pubs pour des
petites marques comme samsung peugeot ou
encore armani pour la féliciter bref
tout vous sourirez au pays à 38 ans vous
marcher sur l'eau mais ça n'a pas
toujours été le cas effectivement vous
revenez de loin alors on va raconter un
peu votre histoire vous avez tout juste
deux ans quand votre mère rejoint une
secte dans les deux sèvres elle s'y
installe avec vous et votre frère aîné
quels sont vos premiers souvenirs de
cette secte
c'est difficile à dire
parce que parce que j'ai complètement
fait abstraction et j'avoue ce qui est
ce qui est assez dingue c'est que là
j'ai 38 ans et j'ai oublié
absolument vraiment les
90% de mon enfance je n'ai pas vraiment
eu d'enfance donc je me souviens de très
très peu de choses oui ça des faits un
black out total a complètement bloqué à
toi vous allez donc grandir dans cette
communauté tenu d'une main de fer par
une femme une maîtresse femme ou et est
exactement est-ce que vous avez souvient
comment s'appelait cet endroit
c'était dans la région d de sel et il y
avait donc la maison mère dont deux de
la secte et après nous on avait maison à
côté ou après on vivait aussi avec des
idées des gens vivre avec nous et tout
est dit et diriger effectivement par
cette femme par cette fameuse roue
qui était absolument
maintenant complètement folle vous dites
que cette femme était complètement folle
de fait les rejets enquêtait sur elle et
la chance que vous avez eue dans votre
malheur c'est qu'elle vous a laissé
aller à l'école pour ne pas être en
infraction avec la loi est-ce que
l'école ça a été votre seul lien avec le
monde réel elle réussit vous faire des
copains de cette époque là vous étiez de
fête marginalisés vous êtes c'est
différent a complètement c'est
complètement marc lépine on le disait
qu'on était différent c'est à dire la
secte vraiment le disent et tuer tuer
tuer tuer spécial mais pas spécial jure
t bien mais sur le tt à part les autres
comprennent pas ce qui se passe machin
c'était donc c'était quand même c'était
très compliqué alors revenons à un
endoctrinement qu'est-ce qu'il vous
disais cette femme
aux enfants la communauté vous étiez
quoi une centaine de ballons en touche
je pense qu'il y avait une centaine vous
mais s'était étalée sur différentes
maisons
donc c'est c'était un peu
ce que c'était très bizarre parce qu'il
y avait cette notion est évidemment de
dieu donc un test de syncrétisme on
prend des différends avaient un peu le
bouddhisme un peu mais en fait elle
faisait ce qu'elle voulait parce que au
final elle prenait je me souviens
qu'elle prenait absolument tout quelques
elle est énormément dans le matériel
dans l'argent on voit pas quand on
habitait au château qui a qu'elle venait
puis apprenait ce qu'elle voulait
prendre et elle avait tellement de
pouvoir sur tout le monde qu'elle
traitait tout le monde avec avec
beaucoup de mépris et c'est pour ça je
me laissais c'est bizarre ce que c'est
si on apprend que dieu et 60 soit disant
amour et bonté et compassion comment ça
se fait qu'on veut on nous tape dessus
qu'on
vraiment premiers souvenirs plus ou
moins atroces a envie de dire cessé
d'être ouais c'est d'être assis sur une
chaise pour nantes une toute toute une
journée d'étude bouge pas pu taton là et
ça c'est c'est voilà à quoi ou bien rasé
les cheveux
qui a cassé la personnalité tout cas
c'est tout cas c'est le rapport avec la
mer le rapport tout casser vous aviez
des séances de châtiments corporels ou
vous raconter que 40 personnes
pourraient vous frapper dessus pour vous
faire sortir les goûts c'était louis
encasté beau on enlève les go donc
effectivement
de comment ça se passait
voilà pas grand chose à
se retrouve que dans le salon autres et
puis et puis voilà puis cette espèce de
mais c'est pas vraiment ce qu'est ce qui
est marrant c'est que comme je pense
qu'on a tous regardé hollywood on
s'attend à mais ça fait par quelque
chose de spectaculaire voilà mais en
fait quand on était plus un ch'ti et si
dieu plus sournois complètement puis ça
faisait c'était parti surtout du
quotidien donc on se rend pas compte
qu'elle était ce quotidien justement
parce que est ce que vous pouvez m'en
parler de ce quotidien
c'est difficile parce que parce que déjà
il ya tellement trop mac on l'a oublié
mais en plus de ça
c'est comme si vous me demandez mais
c'est quoi votre quotidien à vous dans
la journée ça faisait partie de notre
vie en fait c'est sûr surtout dans la
tête et c'est à dire un truc qui me
revient d'être absolument présents dont
tout ce qu'on faisait
moi je me rappelle lamoureux qui venait
et si je prenais mon verre d'eau j'étais
pas la regarder mon verre d'eau à
essayer du coup je me faisais je me
faisais taper dessus je me faisais voilà
c'était et c'était beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d' humiliations énormément
d'humiliation devant tout le monde et ça
je crois que ça une des choses les plus
dures je rends tout cas pour moi
parce que c'était vraiment une
humiliation quotidien de progrès pour
tous donc il fallait toujours essayé de
faire attention à ce qu'on faisait et où
seront ce qu'on pensait ce qu'on disait
la façon dont se tenait tous vous vous
souvenez du nom de cette secte
cet acte avait pas vraiment de nom parce
que c'était des noms de maison donc la
gourou avec plusieurs personnes acheter
maison et après le dernier en date
c'était c'était un château dans les deux
sèvres ça c'était vraiment les toutes
les dernières années donc
jusqu'à sa se trouvait sont encore là
bas ils deviennent dernière fois où je
me suis retrouvé là bas c'est la
dernière fois je me suis retrouvé là bas
veillez 18 ans j'avais juste juste avant
18 ans et
et je me souviens qu'on m'avait emmené
la barre
et j'arrive dans le salon et ils étaient
tous assis tout ça vous regardé comme si
j'étais
le diable je ne sais quoi et elle a été
sur un troll mais vraiment et moi je
vois ça
et ça m'avait elle a même regardé et m'a
dit si tu parles de quoi que ce soit tu
vas te retrouver à la rue tira à la dass
tu n'auras rien et là moi dans ma tête
j'étais là mais qu'est ce que c'est que
c'était fou c'était fou ai-je été
achetés terrorisme c'était absolument
rien dans cette secte était interdite
absolument tout pas de télé pas de radio
encore moins de téléphone pas de livres
pas de jeu n'ont plus aucune fenêtre sur
le monde vous êtes totalement coupés du
monde isolé enfermé punir c'est le
principe carcéral
je ne sais pas parce que c'est pas
c'était c'est pas aussi noir et blanc
que ça c'était vraiment pas rendre les
livres 1 pu lire des livres mais après
il fallait c'était très c'était très
sélectionnés les lire ou pas rethel qui
a s'est elle terminée c'est elle qui
détermine absolument tout l'actrice et
réalisatrice sarah su qu a vécu dix ans
dans une secte religieuse et effets de
cet enfant sous emprise un film
magnifique les éblouit est ce que vous
l'avez vu non vous ne vous n'auriez pas
envie de le voir ce serait trop
non violent way a taillé des chants à
écouter de la musique de regarder des
films de sortir les cheveux au vent de
porter des pantalons pour les filles la
scène ne se passe pas chez les talibans
mais en france dans certaines
communautés charismatiques un peu comme
la vôtre sarr a su qu'on vous raconte
très bien seul à le penser notamment que
la marque philips inscrits sur les
cassettes audio qu'elle écoutait et le
nom d'un groupe indé vous aussi vous
avez littéralement été coupée du monde
jusqu'à vos 18 ans et que vous découvrez
qui est michael jackson non mais
regardez pas
des émissions de télé ou non plus du
tout vous regardez pas les infos en gaz
non pas du tout donc vous et on peut
dire que vous êtes né un peu à 18 ans
quasiment est quasiment parce que c'est
vrai qu'on n'avait pas mais mais quand
même vous expliquer en même temps nous
on était à l'école donc on avait des
petits trucs mais c'était pas on aurait
pu me dire milk et c'est le président
que je sois bon voilà quoi oui ça va du
coup raconte que ce qui lui a permis de
tenir c'est le théâtre vous ça a été le
piano vous découvrez un jour ce piano et
vous commencez à jouer dira comment se
fait-il que ce piano qui était interdit
et été laissés là à l'abandon et qu'on
vous ait laissé le
l'approché je sais pas mais j'ai eu de
la chance parce que c'est vrai amour
c'était oui je peux ajouter toujours
fait et c'est vraiment
je me suis accroché à sa absolument
toute ma vie
à tel point qu'ils m'ont bible ou même
j'en faisais trop donc la gaule 110 mm
par an le ventre quand j'avais 14 ans je
crois vous perdez votre meilleur ami à
ses théories mais vous commencez à jouer
à l'instinct savent que comment comment
ça se passe vous vous découvrez ce piano
à 4 5 ans oui mais ça c'est bon c'est
gégé plus de souvenirs de louer notre
cerveau quand ils marchent regarde le
positif des as qui me fait sourire parce
que c'est vrai que ça c'est pour moi la
chose la plus belle bah oui j'ai appuyé
ce 22 août j'entends des uns sont et ce
sont ça me parlait comme c'était comme
un langage en fait et du coup je jeu
jallet sur le piano et j'ai ajouté des
notes ensemble c'est comme ça c'est
comme ça que j'ai découvert vraiment
l'instrument et et en faisant ça après
je le faisais dans ma tête comme il y
avait énormément de moments où on se
faisait punir ou autre et des moments où
on avait le droit absolu rien faire je
veux rester juste assis sur une chaise
toute une journée ah ouais vous
composiez dans votre tête donc je
composais tous dans nos têtes le piano
dit vous c'était un moyen de communiquer
c'était aussi votre façon d'exister est
carrément
oui pour moi ccc vivent d'ailleurs
encore aujourd'hui chaque piano pour moi
et les pianos vraiment boissons sont
vivants et sont complètement différents
et c'est et une conversation c'est clair
et en fait j'ai l'impression comme si
c'était un peu un code en fait donc
comme c'est un morceau c'était un code
qui
transforme tout toutes ces émotions
qu'ont qu'on lâche et on les met à
travers à travers la musique puis moi
c'est et le médium le piano c'est ça qui
était assez clair ces magazines et 11 je
voulais faire que ça alors à 18 ans vous
partez fuyez fait un stop au
commissariat vous portez plainte non non
je n'ai pas porté plainte parce que
j'avais des frères et soeurs plus jeunes
donc j'ai fait une main courante j'ai
essayé de réfléchir aux quais ou bien et
vont être à la dass où ils vont sortir
et et j'ai appris qu'ils sont sortis peu
de temps après
donc
donc voila quoi c'est à ce n'est pas
génial mais j'ai porté à une main
courante a échoué parti et où est-ce que
vous échouez en fait ce qui s'est passé
c'est que je
j'essayais de faire des études je
travaillais un petit boulot et puis je
suis parti à los angeles je me suis dit
je leur ai américain le rêve américain
qui est vraiment un rêve
totalement ce que j'entends par le rêve
américain c'est que ça s'est mal passé
c'était très difficile c'était une belle
expérience je le regrette pas cette wave
mais c'était très compliqué ce qui s'est
passé pendant ce temps un peu plus d'un
mois quand même je me suis retrouvée
je me suis retrouvé à la rue se
retrouver c'était très difficile puis
j'avais pas de visas non plus donc
c'était très difficile après n'est pas
simple il tient du parcours du
combattant entre paris et londres bitume
squats ou colloques vivait d'expédients
de petits boulots carburé aux idées
suicidaires
qui ou quoi vous à sortir de cette
ornière à londres
j'étais à reading et à reading je
travaille dans un magasin de musique
jean des pianos et là il ya un homme qui
s'appelle michael freeman qui
nous entend jouer qui en gros voilà qui
est qui qui monte on joue et qui tombe
un peu amoureux de ma musique cet homme
décide de vous envoyer à oxford étudiait
la musicologie la musique contemporaine
c'est invraisemblable
oui oui oui c'était complètement c'était
des voix s'étaient c'était assez
vraisemblable un très belle âme belle
personne et en fait me retrouve donc
avec une interview voilà et puis et puis
d'aubagne disent écoutez ok on vous
prend j'ai eu une offre inconditionnelle
pour faire de musique contemporaine et
puis je me retrouve à a passé trois ans
à oxford
c'est dingue ouais mais c'est ouais mais
c'est c'était ce qui était chouette
c'est que du coup j'avais une
scor lâche une bourse à une bourse
j'avais une bourse et puis j'avais
trouvé aussi je faisais du piano dans un
dans un hôtel les week-ends je te fais
des petits boulots que je me débrouille
et puis donc ça c'est chouette et j'ai
organisé mes premiers concerts là bas
j'ai rencontré ma femme là bas qui veut
aller vendu les premiers tickets de mes
concerts il ya une autre rencontre
décisive celle avec le producteur nick
sanders oui ça c'était juste après donc
on est on se retrouve en fait sur
myspace à l'époque qui était un peu
l'ancêtre du facebook près et il
découvre ma musique et et m'envoie un
email en dix ans j'adore ta musique est
ce qu'on peut se rencontrer moi je
produis des films auxquels est bloqué
c'est ça ouais et donc je vais à londres
et et on se rencontre et puis mme
thibout fini tes études appui vient à
londres et est ce tu veux moi j'aimerais
bien te manager de voilages adorent
thème musique et tout puis avoir cette
opportunité
hélas oui je je commence à faire a joué
surtout en fait partout je trouve des
pianos je joue effectivement nick me
présenta les personnes et un jour ils
organisent un dîner pour vanity fair et
rebelote troisième rencontre
alors ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'on sa
voisine et l éditrice en chef de vanity
fair de londres il y en gros appareil
qui est tombée amoureuse de ma musique
est en fait je reçois un coup de fil
dans l'âme invite à un dîner en tant
qu'invité et et à me dire
j'aimerais que tu joues en morceaux de
musique et puis on opéra mail pandore je
le dis parce que je pense que c'est ce
que pour moi c'était voilà j'étais
c'était beaucoup d'argent c'est énorme
et la première fois qu'on allait me
payer et que j'allais jouer j'ai les
oies acheter là c'est extraordinaire
donc je me retrouve à ce dîner avec tout
le un peu plus le gratin tout le gratin
londres moi évidemment j'avais pas
forcément de culture populaire nous
mêmes et il y avait vraiment tout le
monde et pire on voyait aussi c'est dans
ces soirées là la façon dont les gens
sont habillés la façon de risque
comporte outre l'impression peut être
l'at l'intrus
l'imposteur même poste à l'imposteur 7
l'imposteur que quand on grandit comme
j'ai grandi c'est vrai que tout de suite
on se sent toujours un peu un poster et
donc je vais m'asseoir à ma place et au
milieu du dîner ting ting ting on a
invité spécial jean philippe riou pied
alors à moi j'étais tétanisée j'écris
vraiment cru que j'allais m'évanouir ce
que c'était s'était énormément de
pression pour moi et là je vois chris
martin et donc elle est là encore plus
de pression parce que bon quand même
c'est un musicien un qui a eu le
musicien de coldplay c'est voilà le
musicien coldplay qui est quand même et
puis moi c'était le seul album vraiment
le seul album que j'ai écouté quand je
suis du coup je suis parti de mélange
est justement celui que vous avez écouté
s'étaient arrachées par j'écoutais ça
sous la neige tout seul un pour noël
tout seul sans personne est vraiment
comme un iceberg et bcsa et et a pleuré
toutes les larmes de mon coeur avec cet
album qui était quand même relativement
tellement très émotionnel
c'était je fais plus en 2001-2002 et
disons plus tard avoir trouvé à jouer
face à lui devant lui devant lui quoi et
donc je joue je joue mon truc et et là
je donne tout ce que j'ai et à la fin
gros silence agi seul a donc un peu le
club toujours cette phase de l'imposture
et là je me lève et tout le monde
applaudit les gens se lèvent shauna que
j'ai vraiment l'impression d'avoir raté
et en fait pas du tout et du coup je me
lève et la crise qui me fait signe viens
viens viens chez moi et me dire c'était
fabuleux et il me demande de rester avec
lui apte à moi j'étais très jeune on
merci j'avais donc je retourne la table
et puis je vais à dix minutes plus tard
et il s'en va en fait et du coup il fait
tout le tour de la salle et vient me
voir il me fait un gros câlin et il me
dit à quel point c'était beau et il fait
encore plus que ça encore plus que ça il
voulait il voulait m'aider et mon
manager a fait une blague en disant en
anglais ces écoutes de oued au piano et
abattant un piano ça pourrait être cool
et puis écrit ce qu'il dit pas la
laisser pour lui offrir un piano ou quoi
et du coup il m'a offert un piano et sur
lequel vous avez enregistré votre
premier album voilà mon album hoyaux
figé enregistrait ça dans mon
appartement à londres en mettant des
matelas sur les murs est vrai sonorisée
on vous lit pour insonoriser créer une
atmosphère et j'avais mon ingénieur du
son avec qui je travaille d'abord à
vendre leur production à l'époque et
voilà j'ai passé une semaine enregistrée
c'était super alors tous enchaîne les
albums les concerts les contrats de plus
en plus nombreux de plus en plus
prestigieux mais en 2015 alors que la
vie vous sourit vous sombrer dans la
dépression l'alcool la drogue a de
nouveau le passé vous rattrape à quelle
branche vous raccrochez vous cette fois
alors ce qui s'est passé c'est que toute
ma vie j'ai une dépression évidemment
mais une dépression qui était qui était
tellement tellement tellement ancrée et
j'ai découvert plus tard évidemment
l'épigénétique la génétique ou ce que je
me suis intéressé à tout ça mais je
pensais au quai le jour où je gagne ma
vie le jour où je fais ce que j'aime et
voilà et je suis pas encore à la rue je
n'ai pas à m'inquiéter de l'argent
m'inquiéter je vais être bien ça va me
guérir et c'est pal c'était pas le cas
je me retrouve ces tests et 2013 où
j'avais j'avais mon piano j'ai mon
appartement je gagne ma vie je voyage
partout où je vais je fais des concerts
en chine je vais aux usa c'est
incroyable et je suis toujours dépressif
et cette douleur là c'est une douleur ou
où tous les matins tous les matins à
voir c'est une boule qui maquille marron
j'ai toute ma vie et je me dire j'y
arrive pas et du coup effectivement on
se retrouve dans des milieux je me
retrouve avec avec tout ce milieu de de
l'argent du faux guides et les soirées
et les bois le bois parce que bon bah je
découvre ça je bois je fais c'est de
faire la fête mais pour moi je j'ai
tellement une vie entre guillemets
difficile que du coup je ne pouvais pas
être aussi je pouvais pas être aussi
superficiel c'était un peu difficile et
est du coup bas ce qui est intéressant
déjà c'est une des cuvées le lendemain
je me réveillais avec désole un oeil au
beurre noir je me retrouvais avec les
menottes avec les flics pour vendre des
trucs mais des trucs complètement
aberrant et j'étais très très très
malheureux donc j'ai tenté de me
suicider plusieurs fois évidemment parce
que parce que je voulais arrêter et au
final jour où tout est censé aller bien
ça va toujours pas bien et à quoi vous
vous raccrochez à ce moment là qu est ce
qu est-ce qui vous sauve qu'est-ce qui
vous sort de cette ornière encore une
fois ma femme qui m'avait dit à l'époque
mais qui n'était pas encore ma femme va
faire du yoga et jetés là non
et puis j'y suis allé je vais faire du
yoga chou et j'y allais quasiment tous
les jours parfois même deux fois par
jour ça ça commençait à m'aider il finit
faut que j'arrête j'ai arrêté de fumer
des pétards j'ai arrêté de jouer au
lendemain de deux je suis devenu
végétarien je me suis mis à jeûner et à
lire tout ce que je pouvais trouver sur
le cerveau je vous dis ok je voulais
comprendre comment ça marche comment
est-ce que et il ya un truc fabuleux
c'était les ondes cérébrales et j'ai vu
des expériences un peu
un peu on va dire un peu un peu mystique
se retrouver avec des expériences assez
de rêve lucide un peu de sorties de
corps des trucs un peu et évidemment le
premier truc qu'on veut que je me suis
dit c'est bon est ce que c'est est-ce
que c'est réel est ce que est ce que
c'est un rêve et du coup je me suis mis
à lire encore plus là dessus donc je me
suis mis à lire vraiment aux quais
commencent à vos marges comment et j'ai
lu des études et notamment un des
pionniers des rêves lucides
stéphane laberge j'ai lu un des premiers
bouquins c'est énorme en dodge à un
psychiatre américain qui a du coup qui
explique la neuroplasticité d'argent qui
est relativement c'est pas nouveau mais
ça rentre dans les moeurs c'est assez
récent et c'est ça qui m'a aidé à me
dire ok donc en gros tout ça il faut que
je reprogramme mon cerveau est comme moi
mon cerveau il a été programmé toute ma
vie avec cette dépression et j'avais ça
en moi toute ma vie et donc rien ne
pouvait sortir mais c'était à moi de
changer mes habitudes et vous ré encoder
c'est exactement ça demeurez encoder et
je savais que j'étais très heureux quand
je faisais de la musique je rentrais en
transe à chaque fois je faisais de la
musique mais et je peux pas faire la
musique 28 heures sur 24 ça le problème
donc du coup j'ai même acheté un électro
encéphalographie
sélectif halle aux grains puis
hadji ou pour mesurer les ondes
cérébrales et j'ai vu que vous pouvez
les modifier quelques mots du lait et du
coup j'ai commencé à faire dd encore
plus de recherches là dessus et moi
aussi en fabriquer donc j'ai même
fabriqué des monsieur amusé à fabriquer
des sons pour mais voilà l'explication
des 300 millions d' écoute parce que ce
que vous faites c'est de la musique
méditative ya quelque chose de
d'ailleurs tous les prof de yoga de
méditation ce sa rage vos morceaux ah
oui c'est vrai oui c'est
vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
l'utilisent et comme on vit dans un
monde
relativement difficile c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire du coup je pense qu'il
ya beaucoup de gens qui ont envie de se
sentir bien sûr mais on a le sentiment
qu'il ya quand même quelque chose de
deux à la fois de méditatif et de
mathématiques dans votre dans votre
musique est vrai qu on en écoute un
extrait
[Musique]
oh
où
c'est marrant parce que vous êtes
presque sous hypnose quand on vous
écoute et
alors
je passe avons fait c'est un peu le boss
que vous étiez là à 1 g de mardi je
parte
je pars dans ce qu'ils font ce que
j'appelle un peu le le point de
conscience où je pense plus c'est ce que
j'arrête de penser enfin voilà donc un
lieu où rien ne vaut un rien ne vous
cogne ouais ouais ouais un lieu
débarrassé de tout espace de sessa des
douleurs ou vous pacifié complètement et
c'est ça que pour moi en tout cas ma
musique c'est là dessus que tout petit
c'est le one man menait dans dans cet
été mais c'est aussi
toute cette misère qui crée un peu le
way le côté mathématique je pensais
c'est certainement les toc ce qui est
très intéressant c'est que de cette
enfance volée cabossée il vous reste des
stigmates qui s'apparente presque à un
stress post traumatique et qui se
manifeste et lecture par des toques vous
passez votre temps à compter tout tout
le temps en permanence un coucou
convenant tout mais tout le temps
il faut que ce soit effectivement bien
symétrique ouais c'est très important la
symétrie très très important là il ya
trois spots 1-1 2-3 2-1 2-3 j'ai fait ça
je ne suis pas 200 fois
c'est oui mais si je pense que ça a créé
complètement ce rythme dans ma musique
mais comment comment avez vous vécu le
confinement rio puis parce que j'imagine
que vous retrouvé enfermé n'a pas dû
être simple pour vous ou le contraire on
a l'habitude du coup c'est
ça c'est ça c'est non ça s'est
relativement bien passé parce que
effectivement ça a changé
toute ma vie parce que je voyage est
tout le temps absolument tout le temps
donc du jour au lendemain - voyager
c'est à dire moi j'avais beaucoup chiner
les unissent et surtout laissé deux
endroits
donc rester plus en europe faire des
choses un peu plus local ses sets
c'était plus compliqué mais de l'autre
côté j'ai deux petits bébés donc c'était
sûr vous êtes en venant vous en êtes
occupés complètement nous avions envie
de partager votre expérience dans les
écoles par exemple ou où vous n'avez pas
envie d'en parler
c'est marrant parce que l'on me dit
souvent ça que ça peut aider les gens
j'espère que ma contribution de pour moi
elles se trouvent déjà au niveau de la
musique l'impressionnante cc voilà jeu
et je fais de plus en plus maintenant
effectivement aussi de morceaux pour
pour la méditation parce que je pense
que ses cheveux sur un grand avocat de
la méditation jeu ça deux fois par jour
tous les jours et c'est vrai que c'est
incroyable comme ça je dis rien on parle
pas du tout de de spiritualité ce que
c'est pareil moi j'ai grandi en sec donc
la spiritualité j'étais là n'ont ni
dogme et religion je suis un peu contre
ça mais purement scientifiquement on
voit aujourd'hui qu'effectivement bon à
prendre soin de nous de notre corps de
notre tête ça va nous aider à aller
mieux les sectes je pense que il faut il
faut il faudrait effectivement parler
mais je sais pas si je suis la meilleure
personne nous pourrons parler parce que
c'est encore très émotionnelle pour moi
je pensais avoir franchement fermer la
porte il ya près de 20 ans et il avait
fait entendre la ré ouvert et
oui et j'essaie de pas trop la réouvrir
parce que j'ai pas envie de faire du mal
j'en tire deux mois où je renoue avec
une famille ma soeur j'ai pas vu presque
15 ans donc j'ai pas envie de leur faire
du mal j'ai pas envie de leur c'est un
tabou n'en parle jamais
il faut avancer il faut avancer c'est je
veux pas retourner dans le passé parce
que c'est c'est pas beau et puis je
voudrais juste vous voulez c'est le mot
de la fin quand vous envie de dire à
ceux qui nous écoutent et ceux qui nous
regardent et qui
seraient susceptibles d'avoir traversé
ce que voulaient traverser
de trouver son propre chemin à soi je
pense que c'est important de d'écouter
les autres mais de jamais ne jamais
penser que quelqu'un c'est mieux que
vous et vous disent que vous avez à
faire et se retrouver sous l'emprise de
quelqu'un je pense que ça c'est très
très très très dangereux merci merci
beaucoup
[Musique]